spoonful of Cala loaded on your ship now
what if you tried to scoop the sun with
a teaspoon you'd only get about 2 kg of
it the same amount of a neutron star
would weigh anywhere from 1 billion to 6
billion tons you wouldn't be able to
lift that spoon in the first place and
that's not even the worst
part because the gravity of a neutron
star is so intense it fuses protons and
electrons together only neutrons are
left in that Stellar core when they
aren't buried down inside a star
neutrons don't last too long after 10
minutes the scoop of a neutron star
would break down into protons and
neutrons and release as much energy as
the sun produces in 2 or 3
seconds good thing you didn't have
enough time to bring that stuff back to
Earth leave neutron stars where they
belong far far away from
us